you were talking about how lot of
entrepreneurs don't think bigger they
don't see themselves as world changers
and it may be a fact of their
environment just that they don't have
people in their lives that support them
is it that nobody's ever made them aware
of the impact and so they think small
like why do entrepreneurs play such a
small game in general what do you think
it's simply first Evan because they're
not entrepreneurs so understand when you
say entrepreneurs I understand that and
solopreneurs I understand that and da da
dadadada da if this and that if they own
a business they're entrepreneurs it's
just a tag for most people who aren't
really entrepreneurs entrepreneurs
entrepreneurship the entrepreneurial
spirit is that intense curiosity that I
talked about earlier it's that intense
curiosity asking the question what's
missing in this picture why is it people
are so screwed up why is it the world is
so screwed up why is it that you
understand what I'm saying this constant
and as you begin to do that your
curiosity takes over and your curiosity
is the heart of that entrepreneurial
spirit within it always starts with why
why is it who am i what am I doing here
why am I here what is life what is death
what is God what does it mean to be a
human being what is being mean and on
and on and if you are curious about that
you then open yourself to all of the
channels of influence that are simply
sitting there around you and as you open
yourself to those channels of influence
you're inundated with promise because
every single question has an answer that
leads you to another question which has
an answer which leads you to another
question and it's a never-ending
says of continuous pursuit of
improvement the world can be a
stunningly creative place but only if
you cease yes but and open the doors to
your imagination so join me in opening
the doors to your imagination and you'll
suddenly see things you've never seen
before it's that which is so absolutely
astonishing